Cari, warte mal, ich bin noch nicht ganz bereit.
Ich muss noch die Inauguration von Joe Biden
zum neuen Präsident(en) der Vereinigten Staaten
zu Ende gucken.
Ja, zeig mal.
Ich sehe gar nichts.
Hier, kannst du meinen Bildschirm sehen.
Pence und Harris auf der Treppe.
Oh.
Herzlichkeiten werden ausgetauscht.
Wir sehen Mike Pence und seine Frau und Kamala
Harris und ihren Ehemann auf der Treppe.
Ja, Manuel.
Heute ist ein historischer Tag in den USA,
bei uns ist es ein ganz normaler Tag.
Wir haben gerade live mitgeguckt beim großen
Season Finale der USA … oder nee, Staffelanfang,
Anfang der neuen Season sozusagen.
Interessant.
Ich habe heute Morgen Jeremy gefragt, ob man
das denn in den USA, ob das jeder guckt, weil
wir hatten diese Angst, dass wir einen Livestream
machen und gleichzeitig die Amtseinführung
von Joe Biden stattfindet.
Ist jetzt …
Ja, er hat das glücklicherweise so getimt,
dass wir, dass er quasi vor uns das macht
und das Feld räumt für unseren Livestream.
Pre-Act sozusagen, auf, wie nennt man das
dann auf Deutsch?
Der …
Die Vorband.
Wir haben also gerade die Amtseinführung
geguckt und ich habe ihn gefragt, ob das in
den USA jeder guckt, weil das ist ja schon
so sehr pompös, könnte man sagen, ne?
Das wäre vielleicht ein gutes Wort.
Und er meinte, es guckt aber jetzt nicht jeder,
aber es ist ja schon ein … Also, ich habe,
wir haben ja gerade schon zusammen ein bisschen
geguckt in der Vorbereitung auf unsere Sendung
heute.
Es ist schon ein feierlicher Akt mit Lady
Gaga, J.Lo, den ganzen alten Präsidenten
und da haben wir uns gefragt: Wie läuft das
eigentlich in Deutschland ab?
Das ist etwas, an das ich mich gar nicht erinnere.
Wie sah das denn aus, als Angela Merkel ihren
Amtseid abgelegt hat oder als Bundeskanzlerin
ins Amt gekommen ist?
Genau, ich habe das mal rausgesucht auf YouTube.
Vielleicht können wir das kurz einblenden
für die, die jetzt live zuschauen und im
Podcast werden wir das verlinken in den Show
Notes.
Also das war 2005, hier eine noch deutlich
jüngere Doktor Angela Merkel und ich spiele
das einfach mal ab.
Frau Bundeskanzlerin, ich bitte Sie, zur Eidesleistung
zu mir zu kommen.
Zur Eidesleistung.
Das heißt, also wir sehen jetzt hier den
Bundestag.
Das ist also nicht draußen irgendwie, sondern
vor dem … das ist einfach mitten im Parlament
und sie geht jetzt …
Keine Party.
… ganz trocken nach vorne und dort steht
jetzt Norbert Lammert, der damalige …
Bundestagspräsident.
Frau Bundeskanzlerin, ich möchte Sie bitten,
den Eid zu leisten.
Ich schwöre, dass ich meine Kraft dem Wohle
des deutschen Volkes widmen, seinen Nutzen
mehren, Schaden von ihm wenden, das Grundgesetz
und die Gesetze des Bundes wahren und verteidigen,
meine Pflichten gewissenhaft erfüllen und
Gerechtigkeit gegen jedermann üben werde,
so wahr mir Gott helfe.
So wahr mir Gott helfe.
So, das war der Amtseid, ohne große Bibel.
Ja, was ist denn das da?
Er hält … das ist wahrscheinlich das Grundgesetz.
Das ist … wahrscheinlich.
Und jetzt klatschen die Abgeordneten und das
finde ich jetzt besonders spannend, das, der
Blick von Angela Merkel, weil sie fühlt sich,
glaube ich, noch etwas unwohl in ihrer Haut.
Stimmt!
Krass.
Ja, sie guckt sehr unsicher, kann man sagen,
ja?
Sie guckt nicht … das ist ja, ihre erste
Kanzlerschaft ist das, ne?
Ja.
Und jetzt kommt das Beste, weil jetzt wird
die Veranstaltung beendet.
Sie sieht so jung aus!
Frau Bundeskanzlerin, Sie haben den in der
Verfassung vorgesehenen Eid geleistet.
Ich bekräftige noch einmal die guten Wünsche
des ganzen Hauses.
Bis zur Bekanntgabe der vom Bundespräsidenten
ernannten Mitglieder der neuen Bundesregierung
und ihrer Vereidigung unterbreche ich die
Sitzung bis 16 Uhr.
Die Sitzung ist unterbrochen.
Mittagspause!
Und jetzt guck, jetzt gehen die nämlich auch
alle sofort raus, so: "Okay, ist vorbei, tschüss."
Krass!
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen, Manuel.
Wow, das hat ja wirklich …
Deutlich weniger pompös als bei den Amerikanern.
Also wir haben jetzt gerade den kompletten
Amtseid … In den USA hat das jetzt zwei
Stunden gedauert, ne?
Da kam, ganz lange kam so eine Fanfarenmusik,
dann kamen alle Leute einzeln raus, jedes
Kind, jeder Enkel wurde einzeln aufgerufen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das alles geguckt hast.
Das hat stundenlang gedauert, bis die ganzen
Leute da alle rein- und rausgegangen sind
und ja.
Wir haben jetzt gerade hier zusammen im Podcast
noch mal den Amtseid von Angela Merkel, die
Merkel-Inauguration, in einer Minute zusammen
noch mal miterlebt.
Revue passieren lassen.
So unspektakulär ist das in Deutschland.
Keine Party vor dem Brandenburger Tor, sondern:
"So, Amtseid abgelegt, Mittagspause, tschüss!".
Sehr gut.
Damit haben wir das auch erledigt.
Jetzt wisst ihr, wie das in Deutschland abläuft
und dann würde ich sagen, können wir auch
direkt schon zum nächsten Kapitel hier im
Podcast überleiten, oder?
Was ist denn unser nächstes Kapitel, Manuel?
Unser nächstes Kapitel heißt natürlich
…
Eure Fragen LIVE
Live.
Tatsächlich geht es heute in unserem Podcast
nicht um die Amtseinführung von Joe Biden,
auch nicht um Angela Merkel, das war nur unser
Auftakt.
Wir wollen uns heute mal wieder ganz euch
widmen, und zwar hier live bei YouTube.
Wir haben einige Fragen schon rausgesucht,
die wir heute bear… bearbeiten sage ich
schon, bearbeiten möchten.
Und ihr könnt uns live Fragen stellen.
Weil wir sonst manchmal ein bisschen zu wenig
Aufmerksamkeit diesem Segment schenken, wollen
wir heute die volle Aufmerksamkeit euch und
euren Fragen schenken.
Fragen zu Deutschland, zur deutschen Sprache,
zu … wozu kann man noch fragen, Manuel?
Zu dir, zu mir, zu Deutschland, zu Berlin,
zu Philosophie, alles.
Ich habe da direkt …
Ask us anything.
Ich habe da schon eine vorbereitet.
Ja?
(Ja.)
Wir haben einige nämlich schon in der Vorauswahl
jetzt.
Also ihr könnt jetzt eure guten Fragen überlegen
und schreiben und was ist denn unsere erste
Frage?
Unsere erste Frage, Manuel, kommt heute von
Nancy, und zwar schreibt sie auf Patreon:
"Ich würde sehr gerne die Couchen …", hieß
das jetzt Couchen oder Couches?
Sofas.
"… die Sofas von Cari und Janusz, von denen
ihr oft gesprochen habt, endlich mal sehen."
Das können wir natürlich heute machen, weil
wir live bei YouTu… oh, da ist sie schon.
Wir haben eine Liveschalte zur Couch bei Janusz.
Hallo Janusz!
Janusz, wir hören dich nicht, aber wir sehen,
dass du live auf dem Sofa liegst, schön.
Ich habe da, das wollte ich eigentlich groß
ankündigen.
Ich habe für uns heute eine Live-Kamera vor
der Couch vorbereitet.
Man sieht hier Janusz' Zimmer und seine Couch.
Und die gleiche Couch steht nebenan noch mal
auf der anderen Seite der Wand in der Küche.
Und ja, Janusz sieht, ehrlich gesagt, ziemlich
bequem aus.
Oder, Manuel?
Sehr bequem.
So schaut er uns also zu, beim Bassgitarrespielen.
(Und …) Also für alle, die … ja?
Oh, jetzt ist er schon wieder weg.
Für alle, die das auch noch mal sehen wollen,
die jetzt nicht live dabei waren: Wir werden
das verlinken hier, diesen, dieses Segment,
dann könnt ihr das in den Show Notes noch
mal anschauen.
Ja, das war schon unser Live… unsere Liveschalte
zur Couch.
Ich freue mich, dass Janusz uns jetzt weiterguckt
auf der Couch.
Und dann gehen wir doch direkt zur nächsten
Frage, oder Manuel?
Sehr gerne.
Die nächste Frage kommt über Instagram.
Ich weiß leider nicht von wem, aber … ich
glaube, da war kein Name dabei, aber die Frage
ist: Was sind wir eigentlich von Beruf?
Daraus folgt, dass das, was wir hier machen,
kein Beruf ist.
Nein.
Er schreibt, er oder sie schreibt: "Welches
Studium habt ihr abgeschlossen?"
und dass ihn diese Frage interessiert.
Cari, welches Studium hast du abgeschlossen?
Ich gucke gerade schon in die Fragen.
Entschuldigung, jetzt hast du mich erwischt.
Tatsächlich haben wir einen richtigen Beruf
gelernt.
Mein richtiger Beruf ist … na ja, so ganz
kann man das nicht sagen.
Ich wollte mal Journalistin werden — ist
ja gar nicht so weit weg von dem, was ich
jetzt mache — und da wollte ich etwas studieren,
was einfach, also, Journalismus selber, das
war so schwierig, da reinzukommen.
Ich wollte erst Kommunikationswissenschaften
machen und dann dachte ich, mache ich etwas,
was mir Allgemeinbildung verschafft, deshalb
habe ich Geschichte studiert.
In der Regelstudienzeit oder wie lange hast
du gebraucht?
Regelstudienzeit.
Was ist denn eine Regelstudienzeit, Manuel?
Weiß ich nicht, sechs Semester.
Sechs Semester, ich habe ja Magister gemacht.
Da war, glaube ich, die Regelstudienzeit … weiß
ich gar nicht, fünf Jahre und ich habe, glaube
ich, sechs gebraucht.
Es ging, glaube ich.
Ich habe mich aber auch nicht besonders stark
für mein Studium interessiert, weil ich damals
schon sehr viele andere Sachen nebenbei gemacht
habe.
(Verstehe.)
Und du, Manuel?
Ja, ich habe auch etwas studiert, was mit
dem zu tun hat, was ich jetzt mache, nämlich
Medienproduktion.
Ich hätte zwar damals nicht gedacht, dass
Medienproduktion bedeutet, dass ich am Mittwochabend
live auf YouTube einen Podcast aufnehme, aber
genau.
Ich habe mich beschäftigt mit Video und Audio
und Filmwissenschaften so ein bisschen, ganz
viele verschiedene Sachen haben wir da gelernt
und gemacht.
Das war eigentlich sehr spannend und war genau
das, worauf ich Bock hatte.
Das war mir wichtig, dass ich Spaß habe an
der Sache.
Ja und jetzt bist du ja Medienproduzent.
Also, du hast das hier offiziell studiert,
Manuel.
Ich habe das hier studiert, was wir hier machen.
Du bist der einzige Profi unter uns.
Wir haben gerade schon ein paar nette Kommentare
bekommen zu unserem Warm-up, und zwar hat
Nancy geschrieben: "Meine Kinder haben die
Inauguration von Barack Obama in der Schulklasse
gesehen, weil das so historisch war."
Das ist krass.
So was würde bei uns nicht vorkommen.
Also ich habe ja gerade, wie gesagt, die,
den Amtseid von Merkel … ich weiß nicht,
ob ich ihn zum ersten Mal gesehen habe.
Ich habe ihn auf jeden Fall nie live gesehen,
sondern vielleicht dann abends fünf Sekunden
in den Tagesthemen.
Und Adil schreibt dazu: "Deutsche sind zu
effizient, um so etwas zu feiern hahaha."
Weißt du, was wir früher in der Schulklasse
geguckt haben?
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, im Physikunterricht.
Statt zu lernen, haben wir Fußball-WM geguckt.
(Echt?)
Da waren die Spiele, haben nämlich manchmal
irgendwie so mittags angefangen, da hatten
wir noch Schule, und da hat unser Lehrer gesagt:
"Ach komm, wir gucken das Spiel."
Stimmt. 1994, die WM in den USA, ja?
Bestimmt.
Nee, ich weiß nicht, nee, das war später,
glaube ich.
(Später?)
Ja.
Weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Rafał schreibt, der hat einen super … Rafał
hat eine super, einen super Vorschlag gemacht.
Bei der Amts… beim Amtseid von Angela Merkel,
da hätte doch David Hasselhoff singen können.
Das wäre gut gewesen.
Ich hätte es gut gefunden, aber die Leute
mussten schnell zur Mittagspause, keine Zeit.
Ja, dann haben wir eine Audio-Frage bekommen
von Kurtis aus Oregon, aus den USA, und die
spiele ich jetzt mal ab.
Hallo Cari und Manuel.
Ich heiße Kurtis und wohne in Oregon in den
USA.
Und meine Frage ist: Was sind ein paar wichtige
Lektionen, das (die) ihr gelernt habt durch,
durch diese() Zeit mit Easy German, die (der)
YouTube Kanal und auch Podcast?
Vielen Dank!
Das ist ja nett.
Hallo Kurtis!
Schön … (Hallo Kurtis!)
Ich freue mich immer sehr, wenn wir euch hören.
Ihr könnt uns immer Sprachnachrichten schicken.
Auf easygerman.fm geht das.
Ja, ich habe da so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht
und ich glaube, ich habe jetzt nicht so was
richtig Handfestes, was ich, was mir dazu
einfällt, aber eine Sache, die ich gelernt
habe, grad so in den letzten Monaten oder
seit ich so richtig voll dabei bin bei Easy
German, dass man sich etwas ausdenken kann,
dass man eine Idee haben kann und diese Idee
in die Welt setzen kann und die dann auch
Resonanz findet und Erfolg hat.
Also das klingt natürlich sehr schwammig
und irgendwie so ein bisschen so … weiß
ich nicht, "motivational speaker"-mäßig,
aber für mich …
Ja.
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Also, ich war immer schon jemand, der irgendwie
viele Ideen hatte und viel geträumt hat,
kreative Dinge zu tun, aber das sind dann
immer Dinge gewesen, die entweder nur in meinem
Kopf passiert sind oder die so ganz privat
passiert sind.
Und dass man aber auch einfach was öffentlich
machen kann und das dann auch funktioniert,
also dass uns ja jetzt gerade Leute zuschauen
zum Beispiel, das habe ich erst so in der
letzten Zeit so richtig verstanden.
In der letzten Zeit erst?
Ja.
So in den letzten zwei Jahren, würde ich
mal sagen.
Okay, verstehe.
Das ist schön, das finde ich … ja, ich
habe nichts so richtig.
Also ich habe, glaube ich, super viele Sachen
gelernt.
Vor allem habe ich so krass gelernt, was das
für Leute eigentlich bedeutet, eine Sprache
zu lernen.
Das war, also ich hatte vorher nur so ein
bisschen meine Perspektive, aber dass es so
viele unterschiedliche Geschichten gibt und
wie viel da wirklich auch im Herzen mit verbunden
ist, mit diesem Wunsch, auszuwandern, mit
diesem Wunsch, woanders zu leben, manchmal
aber auch mit der Not, woanders leben zu müssen.
Also, ich bin echt dankbar für diese ganzen
Sachen, die ich erlebt habe und ich habe unendlich
viel gelernt in der Zeit, ja.
Manuel, ich habe eine super Frage, einige,
direkt einige Fragen zum Reisen.
Vielleicht gibt es hier aufgrund der Corona-Zeit
im Moment ein bisschen Reiselust und Fernweh.
Das ist ja ein schönes deutsches Wort, Fernweh.
Und zwar schreibt Behzad: "Wo werdet ihr euch,
wo werdet ihr als Erstes hinreisen, wenn die
Corona-Krise vorbei ist?"
Machst du dir darüber schon Gedanken, Manuel?
Ach, ich reihe mich einfach in deine und eure
verrückten Pläne ein.
Ich weiß, dass du ja den Traum hast, mit
dem Zug bis nach China zu fahren, über Russland
und diverse andere Orte.
Ach, da willst du mitkommen?
Da komme ich gerne mit, ja.
(Okay.)
Oder wir machen eine große Easy German Reise
daraus.
Also, grundsätzlich geht es mir wie dir,
dass ich in Zukunft vor allem noch viel mehr
über reis… über Land reisen will.
Ich weiß aber auch, dass das super kompliziert
ist, weil ich habe ja eine Weltreise gemacht
für zwei Jahre und hatte da auch das Ziel,
so viel wie möglich über Land zu reisen
und wenn man dann einmal da ist, merkt man
plötzlich: Wow!
Also, von Sri Lanka kommt man zum Beispiel
gar nicht mit dem Schiff nach Indien.
Man muss fliegen, es gibt kein Schiff mehr
und so, deswegen ist das, glaube ich, ein
Projekt, was viel Vorbereitung erfordert,
aber das wäre auch so mein Traum.
Aber jetzt so einen bestimmten Ort habe ich
gar nicht.
Wie geht dir das?
Das ist so, man muss dann halt die Ziele realistisch
halten, ne?
Nach Sri Lanka ist halt auch schwierig, wenn
man vor allem die ganzen Nachbarländer nicht
alle auch noch besuche… obwohl hast du ja
gemacht in Indien.
Mir geht das, ich habe mega Fernweh, ich habe
auch mega den Bewegungsdrang.
Ich merke gerade, dass ich noch nie so lange
an einem Ort war wie jetzt und dass mir das
total fehlt.
Aber das ist auch alles Jammern auf hohem
Niveau, wie man auf Deutsch sagt, denn wir
sollen jetzt einfach dankbar sein, dass es
uns gut geht und dass wir, ja, dass wir alles
haben und eine schöne Wohnung haben und jetzt
müssen wir halt einfach mal noch ein paar
Monate hier bleiben.
Und in der Zukunft hoffe ich tatsächlich,
ich will unbedingt mit dem Zug fahren, in
Europa herumfahren und auch gerne bis nach
China.
Und guck mal, da hat nämlich noch jemand
geschrieben, da fehlt der Name: "Hallo Cari
und Manuel, welche Länder möchtet ihr noch
besuchen, die ihr noch nicht besucht habt?"
Also abgesehen von China, sag mal eins.
Ja, ich habe das schon öfter erwähnt: Ich
möchte unbedingt auch längere Zeit durch
den Iran reisen, weil ich habe mit mehreren
Leuten gesprochen, die im Iran waren und die
schwärmen alle von einer unglaublichen Gastkultur
und Gastfreundschaft.
Und natürlich haben viele Länder eine tolle
Gastfreundschaft, aber ich glaube auch, dass
beim Iran vielleicht noch dazukommt, dass
es da gar nicht so viel Tourismus gibt aus
dem Westen, würde ich mal vermuten und ja.
Ich glaube, das ist ein tolles Land und das
wäre so ziemlich weit oben auf meiner Liste.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema Reisen sind.
Ju bidu schreibt: "Was ist das Verrückteste,
das ihr je auf Reisen erlebt habt?"
Oh, da darfst du anfangen, da muss ich erst
mal nachdenken.
Nein, ich wollte nachdenken!
Scheiße.
Tja, das Verrückteste …
Ah, ich weiß!
Da fällt mir spontan was ein, weil ich gerade
auf Facebook daran erinnert wurde, dass wir
vor drei Jahren in Vietnam waren, genau vor
drei Jahren.
Da warst du auf deiner Weltreise und wir waren
erst in Hanoi und haben dich dann in Ho-Chi-Minh-Stadt
getroffen, ne?
Und das ist, eine(s) der verrücktesten Dinge
ist, dass ich mich daran gewöhnt habe, dass
man in Vietnam einfach auf die Straße geht,
obwohl Autos kommen.
Stimmt.
Und Mopeds.
Und da habe ich so ein Video gemacht, wo ich
wirklich einfach, ich habe das, die Kamera
so gehalten, auf der Höhe von meiner Hüfte
ungefähr, und habe wirklich, ich bin einfach
gegangen.
Und das ist völlig gegen mein Sicherheitsgefühl,
dass du auf einer Straße gehst, wo gerade
drei Spuren Autos und noch zehn Mopeds nebeneinander
fahren und keiner stoppt.
Es ist alles wie ein Fluss und du gehst einfach
rein und du musst einfach nur gleichmäßig
gehen und dich darauf verlassen, dass niemand
in dich fährt, sondern alle um dich herum
fließen.
Und die, das ist wie so ein Schwarm, wie so
ein Fischschwarm verteilt sich der Verkehr
um dich herum und das funktioniert einwandfrei.
Richtig.
Und wenn du Angst hast, dann gehst du einfach
nie über die Straße.
Also …
Ja, das ist natürlich schwierig.
Nee, also wenn du Angst hast, kannst du ja,
dann gehst du einfach nicht los und wartest,
bis es eine Pause gibt, aber es gibt dann
manchmal keine Pause.
Das ist vielleicht eine() der verrücktesten
Sachen, die ich erlebt habe.
Das ist wirklich verrückt, ja, ja.
Das übernehme ich direkt mit.
So, dann gehen wir mal weiter, wir haben viele
Sprachen schon.
Also, Santiago schreibt … (Viele Fragen.)
Das ist gar keine Frage: "Sie gestalten eine
neue deutsche Integrationskultur mit.
Ihr seid krass."
Das ist, glaube ich, nur ein Kompliment.
Danke schön, Santiago.
Das ist ein sehr netter Kommentar.
So, Felipe und Leonardo wollen beide wissen,
wie Easy German entstanden ist.
Möchtest du das kurz zusammenfassen?
Nein, das kannst du diesmal machen.
Ich habe die Frage schon so oft beantwortet.
Okay, also die Kurzfassung, ihr könnt auch
auf unserer Website ein bisschen mehr darüber
lesen und auch die allererste Easy German
Folge euch anschauen, easygerman.org ist unsere
Website.
Also, angefangen hat das im Schillergymnasium
in Münster und dort war Janusz ein Medientrainer.
Und das hat eigentlich als Übung begonnen,
als Film-Medien-Übung in einer Medien-AG,
also, eine AG ist eine Arbeitsgemeinschaft.
Das ist so ein freiwilliger Nachmittagskurs.
Und ja, da, so hat das angefangen, als Übung
von Schülern.
Habe ich das gut zusammengefasst?
Hast du super zusammengefasst, Manuel.
Und dann hat Janusz irgendwann, wollte das
Video nämlich hochladen für zwei Mädels
in Vietnam, die Deutsch gelernt haben und
hat dann diese Website namens YouTube entdeckt.
www.youtube.com, was ist das denn?
Da lade ich das mal hoch.
Richtig, ja.
LeoSantos schreibt: "Wie spricht man Quatsch
richtig aus?"
Quatsch.
Das ist Quatsch.
Laber nicht so einen Quatsch.
Du erzählst Quatsch.
Und NBAChickenLover möchte wissen: "Manuel,
bist du heute nervös vor dem Live-Podcast
oder bist du gut vorbereitet?"
Ich bin immer ein bisschen nervös, aber deutlich
weniger als früher.
Und ich wackele zwar so ein bisschen hin und
her, aber das liegt daran, dass ich stehe
und da ist das halt einfach so.
Da will man immer so ein bisschen wackeln.
Weißt du, was ich mache?
Ich habe mir ein Bier geholt, da bin ich weniger
nervös.
(Hilft das?)
Das hilft ungemein.
Henriette hat eine coole Frage.
Henriette heißt sogar cool, falls die so
wirklich heißt.
Die heißt Henriette Kool oder Kool.
"Was ist euer Lieblingsort in Berlin?"
Das ist eine schöne Frage.
Manuel, hast du einen Lieblingsort in Berlin?
Das ist wirklich eine schöne Frage.
Ich war so lange nicht mehr draußen, dass
ich das … Ich weiß.
Also, es ist nicht, ich glaube, es ist nicht
mein Lieblingsort, aber es ist ein sehr cooler
Ort, den ich vor allem auch empfehlen würde
für alle, die als Tourist nach Berlin kommen.
Und die meisten machen das, glaube ich, auch,
aber man kann ja auf die Kuppel vom Reichstag
gehen.
Also das Parlament, der Bundestag, da ist
oben so eine Glaskuppel drauf und die kann
man besuchen und das ist kostenlos.
Man muss sich aber vorher anmelden über das
Internet und dann bekommt man so ein kostenloses
Ticket zugeschickt per E-Mail.
Und das ist einerseits wahnsinnig interessant,
weil man kriegt dann so ein Hör… so ein
Audio… so eine Audiotour und die ist wirklich
interessant, weil man läuft da so durch diese
Spirale in dieser Kuppel immer weiter hoch
und der Audioguide erzählt einem, was man
gerade sieht.
Also dann guckt man so und dann sagt der so:
"Da ist jetzt gerade die Charité, die wurde
dann und dann erbaut."
Und in der Mitte sieht man das Parlament,
also da sieht man das, was wir vorhin gesehen
haben, wo die Abgeordneten sitzen.
Und dann, ganz am Ende ist man quasi fertig
und dann hängt man einfach auf diesem Dach
ab und schaut sich den Sonnenuntergang an
und deswegen ist das ein toller Ort.
Das klingt gut.
Ich war da schon öfters, ich habe aber noch
nie die Audiotour gemacht.
Ich bin immer ohne Infos einfach so rumgelaufen,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, die ist ausnahmsweise gut.
Ich bin sonst auch kein Fan von solchen Audioku…
wie sagt man?
Guides, aber die ist wirklich gut.
Und du?
Hast du einen Lieblingsort?
Mein Lieblingsort in Berlin, mein Lieblingsort
ist, glaube ich, das Tempelhofer Feld.
Das ist einfach … Ich wohne da überhaupt
nicht in der Nähe, deswegen bin ich da auch
nicht so oft, aber das ist so ein verrückter
Ort, ein ehemaliger Flugplatz mitten in Berlin
und der ist heute ein Park.
Also man kann quasi auf der alten Landebahn
da jetzt Skateboard fahren und grillen und
das ist einfach … Ich finde, das ist immer
noch eine der verrücktesten Sachen und auch
der schönsten Orte, weil das jetzt so ein
Erholungsort ist für so viele Menschen.
Man kann das auch gar nicht richtig beschreiben,
finde ich.
Man muss das besuchen, weil es ist kein Park
in dem klassischen Sinne, da sind ja keine
Bäume oder so, das ist einfach eine riesige
Freifläche und das gibt es sonst wirklich
in keiner anderen europäischen Großstadt.
Also, das ist schon was sehr Besonderes.
Stimmt.
Wir können ja mal in den Show Notes … ich
weiß nicht, welche Easy German das war, aber
wir haben letztes Jahr ein Video gedreht auf
dem Tempelhofer Feld, als du Skateboard fahren
gelernt hast, Manuel.
Und da sieht man sehr schön diesen Ort, ja.
Es ist einfach ein … Wir standen da unter
dem einzigen Baum ungefähr, den es gibt.
Und das war, es ist wirklich ein schöner
Ort.
Dżeeej dobrodziej​ schreibt: "Haben Sie
schon mal Eisbaden probiert?"
Also ich, mein, meine neue Routine ist, dass
ich jeden Morgen mich ein bisschen mit der
Wim Hof Method beschäftige und ein Teil davon
ist, dass ich immer kalt dusche und irgendwann
…
Wie kalt denn?
Na, so kalt, wie es geht halt.
Echt?
So kalt, wie es geht?
Ja.
Und dann, so, also im Moment bin ich erst
bei dreißig Sekunden, aber das steigert sich.
Also demnächst bin ich bei zwei Minuten und
irgendwann, also der Wim Hof badet auch in
so Eis richtig.
Wo ich das wohl schon mal gemacht habe, ist
in der Sauna.
Also es gibt ja so große Spas und da, wenn
man aus der Sauna kommt, soll man immer in
so ein Eisbad reinspringen.
Saunalandschaften.
Und das mache ich immer.
Richtig.
Das habe ich mal versucht, das fällt mir
schwer, das stimmt.
Ich habe gehört von Justyna, dass Eisbaden
gerade so ein Trend ist in Polen oder auf
jeden Fall gibt es da viele Memes zu.
Und morgen kommt bei Easy Polish — youtube.com/easypolish
— ein Video über Eisbaden.
Also, die haben da so eine Gruppe besucht
in Katowice, die wirklich mit so einer Axt
im See stehen, das Eis wegbrechen und da schwimmen.
Und dieses Bild ist einfach so geil, wie sie
… Wir sehen da den Moderator() von Easy
Polnisch und er steht da so in so einer Jacke,
mit einer Mütze und allem und im Hintergrund
siehst du Leute in der Badehose ins Wasser
laufen mit einer Axt in der Hand.
Es sieht einfach gut aus.
Ja, also, ich könnte mir vorstellen, das
mal im Meer … also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
im Meer zu schwimmen.
Das würde mir, glaube ich, Spaß machen,
auch wenn es kalt wäre.
Also wenn ich jetzt in der Nähe vom Meer
wohnen würde oder vielleicht mal im Winter
Ferien am Meer machen würde, fände ich das
okay, aber ich muss jetzt nicht jeden Morgen
kalt duschen, ne?
Wenn wir dann irgendwann in Russland sind,
dann … Ach so, warte mal.
Ja.
Das ist hier noch schön von Bruno, das ist
eigentlich eine schwierige Entscheidung, und
zwar: Wenn du für den Rest deines Lebens
entweder nur noch Videos schauen könntest
oder nur noch Podcasts hören könntest, was
würdest du nehmen?
Ja, ich würde, glaube ich, die Videos nehmen,
weil ich habe mehr Video-Gewohnheiten.
Es gibt nicht so viele Podcasts, die ich wirklich
… ich habe ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten,
so Podcasts zu finden, die ich richtig gerne
höre.
Also ich höre so ein paar, vor allem dann,
wenn ich irgendwie Zeit habe, was zu hören
und ich habe auch so einen Lieblingspodcast,
den ich immer höre, und natürlich unseren
Podcast.
Den höre ich mir auch immer an, Manuel, aber
ich habe sehr viel mehr YouTube-Kanäle, die
ich gucke und auch viel mehr … ich verbringe
mehr, ja, nicht unbedingt mehr Zeit, aber
bestimmte Routinen am Tag, zum Beispiel mein
Mittagessen und mein Frühstück finden meistens
mit YouTube statt.
Zumindest das Frühstück, ja.
Bei mir ist es genau umgekehrt.
Ich höre sehr viele Podcasts und liebe das
und liebe gerade daran, dass man das machen
kann, wenn man seine Augen für was anderes
braucht, weil man zum Beispiel gerade Fahrrad
fährt oder so und deswegen würde ich die
Podcasts nehmen.
Und dann könntest du mir erzählen, was auf
YouTube passiert ist und ich würde dir die
Podcasts zusammenfassen.
Problem gelöst.
Das wäre ein, ja, das wäre eine gute Idee,
Manuel.
Okay, ich würde sagen, wir nehmen uns jeder
noch eine Frage.
Wollen wir das machen?
(Ja.)
Und dann war es das.
Oder sagen wir noch zwei, dann haben wir,
dann müssen wir uns jetzt schnell entscheiden.
Das ist jetzt eine schwierige Entscheidung.
Ich nehme mal die Frage von Pokemonmaster89.
Pokemonmaster möchte wissen: "Cari, was machst
du gern?
Hast du Hobbys?"
Ich habe tatsächlich nicht so viele Hobbys,
das ist das Witzige.
Und ich versuche jetzt, so Hobbys zu finden,
Sachen, die ich abends machen kann.
Zum Beispiel habe ich, gucke ich manchmal
jetzt Netflix, ist jetzt nicht so ein tolles
Hobby.
Ich habe jetzt die Tage ein neues Spiel gefunden
von einem Freund, der hat mir das empfohlen.
Der hat gesagt, das ist ein deutsches Rentner-Spiel.
Ich bin gespannt, ob du das kennst.
Das heißt Rummikub.
Hast du das schon mal gespielt?
Nee.
Ah, Rummikub!
Doch, doch.
Also nicht gespielt, aber davon gehört, ja.
Ich wollte dir das jetzt gerade zeigen, aber
in der Umsonst-Version muss man erst Werbung
gucken, bevor das kommt und die läuft noch
ein bisschen.
Und zwar ist das so mit Zahlen und so Zahlen…
wie nennt man das?
So Zahlenkarten und man muss die Zahlen in
bestimmten Kombinationen legen.
Und ja, ich habe von meinem Freund Konrad
gehört, dass das eher ein Rentner-Spiel ist
und mir gefällt das aber total.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen süchtig danach
und spiele das jetzt immer morgens, mittags,
abends.
Ich zeige dir mal, wie das hier so aussieht,
so ein Spiel hier, dann … Ihr könnt das
jetzt bei YouTube sehen, im Podcast kann ich
das beschreiben: Es gibt vier Spieler, es
gibt ein blaues Feld und dann gibt es meine
Kartenreih… oh ich bin dran!
Warte … nee, doch nicht.
Und man muss dann immer so Karten ziehen oder
Karten legen.
Das ist natürlich jetzt peinlich, ich bin
jetzt live in einem Spiel und kann jetzt nicht
mitspielen, Manuel.
Ich bin mal ganz kurz weg.
Das ist mein neues Hobby.
Ja, spannend, also … schön.
Kartenspiel.
Ich sehe, du bist nicht so begeistert.
Ich nehme dann mal die Anschlussfrage von
Jan: "Spielt ihr Computerspiele?"
Ich im Moment quasi gar nicht, würde aber
gerne wieder mehr zocken, wie wir auch sagen,
und ja, plane auch mit der Anschaffung einer
Spielkonsole in näherer Zukunft, um dann
wieder so ein bisschen so Tony Hawk zu spielen
und vielleicht auch das eine oder andere Ballerspiel.
Macht mir schon ein bisschen Spaß ab und
zu.
Du wolltest doch unbedingt dieses Jahr mehr
spielen.
Was ist denn daraus geworden?
Ja, das kommt noch.
Okay.
John fragt, und Isi schickt uns gerade im
Hintergrund die Nachricht, dass schon viele
gefragt haben: "Ist Jeremy wieder gesund?"
Wichtige Frage.
Das ist eine wichtige Frage.
Jeremy ist gesund tatsächlich und es geht
ihm jetzt wieder richtig gut und er sieht
auch richtig fit aus.
Wir gehen jetzt immer so dreimal die Woche
oder so spazieren, immer im Mauerpark, so
eine Runde und wieder zurück und es geht
ihm gut.
Ich werde ihm die Grüße ausrichten.
Vielleicht guckt er auch gerade zu.
Liebe Grüße, Jeremy.
Und er arbeitet, das ist dann bestimmt die
nächste Frage schon, er arbeitet fleißig
an der Seedlang-Mobile App.
Sie kommt bald raus hoffentlich, aber wir
können noch kein Datum sagen.
Er arbeitet daran.
Manuel.
(Ja?)
Hast du noch eine?
Letzte Frage: "Was ist euer Lieblingsessen?"
Da bin ich sehr deutsch, ich liebe Kartoffeln.
Ich mag Kartoffeln in allen Formen, egal,
ob jetzt … wie nennt man das?
Bratkartoffeln oder …
Okay Manuel, da habe ich direkt eine Challenge
für dich: Nenn doch mal deine Top Fünf Kartoffelgerichte
in aufsteigender Reihenfolge.
Also, mir fällt gerade nicht ein, wie heißt
denn das, wenn das ein Mus ist?
Kartoffelbrei.
Kartoffelbrei!
Kartoffelbrei ist schon mal großartig.
Bratkartoffeln, wenn sie sehr gut gemacht
sind, sind auch sehr gut.
Pommes esse ich gerne.
Ich esse auch gerne gekochte Pellkartoffeln
und Kartoffelgratin.
Da sind meine Top Fünf.
Und ist das auch die richtige Reihenfolge
gewesen?
Ich glaube schon.
Eventuell würde Kartoffelgratin noch vor
Pommes kommen, aber schwierig.
Schön, das sind die Top Fünf Kartoffelgerichte.
Bei mir sind noch Kartoffelpuffer dabei.
Kartoffelpuffer.
Reibekuchen mit Apfelmus esse ich sehr gerne.
Ja, sehr lecker.
Gut, da haben wir doch wieder einige typisch
deutsche Themen bearbeitet heute.
Ja und viele Fragen.
Ich freue mich, das war schon wieder viel
zu kurz.
Wir haben noch so viele Fragen, schickt uns
gerne weiterhin Fragen.
Auf easygerman.fm könnt ihr uns eure Fragen
schicken, gerne auch mit Audio.
Wir spielen das dann gerne im Podcast ab und
beantworten das in den nächsten Episoden,
denn wir haben ja drei Podcasts pro Woche,
drei Podcast-Episoden und nur einmal im Monat
ungefähr machen wir diesen Livestream.
Das heißt, wenn ihr uns nur hier bei YouTube
jetzt geguckt habt, dann könnt ihr uns viel
öfter hören und wenn ihr uns nur hier im
Podcast hört, dann könnt ihr uns auch zwischendurch
bei YouTube sehen, ne?
Man muss ja immer …
Wir sind multimedial.
… multimedial auf die anderen Plattform
hinweisen.
Und wenn ihr schon alle Podcast-Episoden hört
und alle YouTube-Videos guckt und noch mehr
machen wollt, dann können wir euch sehr herzlich
einladen, ein Mitglied zu werden von Easy
German.
Als Mitglied könnt ihr nämlich direkt mit
uns schreiben und kommunizieren und ihr könnt
tatsächlich auch Zusatzmaterialien erhalten.
Zum Beispiel hier beim Podcast bekommt ihr
das Transkript immer dazu und könnt das Transkript
mitlesen und auch die Vokabeln dazu sehen
und übersetzen.
(Toll.)
Das alles hat Manuel sich selber ausgedacht
dank seines Medienstudiums.
Toll, toll, toll.
Manuel, es hat mich gefreut, heute mit dir
zu quatschen.
Mich auch, wir hören uns Samstag im Podcast-Feed.
Ich habe nur die Hälfte von dem Bier geschafft,
weil ich so viel geredet habe.
Und ich nur die Hälfte von meinem Wasser.
Prost!
(Prost!)
Bis bald.
Bis bald, ciao.
Ciao.